new lockdowns are being put in place in
a number of regions
amidst the ongoing surge in infections
health officials are considering ending
even outdoor dining and in most of
california
stay-at-home orders have been imposed
this a far from festive season for the
small businesses that rely
on holiday trade christmas time coming
that's how
people get the nail done more you know
get beauty for holiday
and now they shut down again the food
and drug administration is set to review
a new vaccine this week it's a process
that in the past would have taken
months but in what amounts to a life or
death situation
health officials are hoping it will take
a matter of hours
based on the data that i know i expect
the fda
to make a positive decision but of
course it's their decision and as you
probably know
they are totally separated and
firewalled from the operation
they will make their own judgment based
on the data and i hope that
the decision will be positive but even
when they are approved
it will take months before the vaccines
are widely available to the general
public
be thinking in the february march time
frame that you're going to see more
general vaccination
and by the second quarter of next year
we'll have enough vaccine for every
american that wants it
as health officials continue to call on
americans to follow social distancing
measures
another member of trump's inner circle
who hasn't followed that advice
has fallen ill to the virus rudy
giuliani
trump's personal attorney was reportedly
hospitalized sunday
after he tested positive he traveled the
country last week
trying to help the president overturn
the election
it was trump who announced his lawyer
hazcobed19
on twitter calling it the china virus
meanwhile the pandemic is claiming the
lives of two
americans every minute heidi joe castro
al jazeera washington